um where does this go think for a moment
okay
and just have a look at all of my minor
signs there's a lot flying around a lot
of manipulation
i subtracted 50 over from both sides and
then i had to multiply through by
minus one so that's change the order of
my difference here
remember it is what i'm trying to solve
right this is a really important point
to stop
and pause i'm trying to solve for the
time
it takes to hit the ground the time it
takes to hit the ground
now at this exact moment the equation
equation's no good for me
right because i don't know the velocity
when i hit the ground if i thought back
to like really simple
projectile motion situations you had
like the equation of path which was just
going to be a parabola
so you had this symmetry to the
situation that you could take advantage
of you could say oh if i'm projecting
upward at 30 meters per second
then my colliding velocity will also be
30 meters per second just in the
opposite direction
but we're an extension too and we're
considering resisted motion right so
because
um the air resistance is pushing against
you and gravity um is
is behaving asymmetrically on the upward
journey as to the downward journey
you can't simply say oh i'm just going
to wait until velocity is 30 again
and then solve for time that's not how
it works when we consider
resistance so what i'm going to do is
get a situation in terms of
displacement i do know what the
displacement will be when i collide with
the ground
i'm calling the maximum height the
origin
so there's y equals zero and as i travel
in the downward direction which is
positive
as i said stated right at the beginning
of this i should hit 32.5
that'll be returning me to the ground in
the positive direction
so i need y in this equation somewhere
right i need to get this not as
v in terms of time but i need it as y
in terms of time or rather time in terms
of y because then i can substitute in y
equals 32.5
so you now have to pause for a minute
and i'm deliberately you can see i've
got my answer ready here to reveal but
i'm pausing to make you think
where can i go with this you are going
to need to make the same kind of
decision
that we made all the way back up here
right we had to think about
the acceleration equation here and say
well which form of acceleration
of stating acceleration like is it this
one is it this one is it this one
which one is the most helpful to
progress you forward right
i've given you a whole lot of flags i
hope they've indicated for you
if i'm trying to take this equation
which is a velocity
time equation and turn it into a
displacement
time equation does it not stand to
reason that the
most helpful way to express velocity
would be the change in displacement with
respect to
time right did you did you anticipate
that coming
if i've got a dy over here and then i
can multiply across by dt
i can integrate just like i did before
it's just with different variables of
integration
with respect to time instead of with
respect to velocity and displacement
earlier
and i'm going to get an equation which
has y's and t's and then off i go
okay so that's what i'm going to do you
can see if i state this
as the y on dt and then integrate with
respect to time
um you're going to get y of course on
the left-hand side you integrate d y dt
you go back to y
and then here is me integrating on the
right-hand side with respect to time
you get that turns into 50t you have to
just be a little bit careful here
because of this awkward um
negative coefficient that's up the top
there so if you think to yourself oh how
do i normally integrate an exponential
if you were say integrating um e
to the two x dx right when you
differentiate you multiply
by the derivative of your inside
function which in this case is the uh
exponent so because i'm integrating now
i should not multiply i should divide so
that would give me this
in this case right when i have a look
over here you can see the
um that the two is not it's not a two
it's a
negative a fifth so i'm dividing this
through by negative a fifth which is the
same as multiplying
by negative five so um you just gotta
keep that part straight in your head so
that's the answer that i get
and then i have a constant of
integration like i did before
so in this case or rather at this point
you can see the advantage of me having
chosen
um to define the maximum height our
beginning of our downward journey
because i've called that the origin i
can now say at time
zero y equals zero so that makes it very
straightforward to go ahead
and evaluate this constant what happens
when you substitute in times zero y
equals zero
this is what you get your y term
just becomes zero as stated your 50t
also becomes zero but just watch out
this is 250 e to the power of zero
e to the power of zero is not zero it's
one
so 250 times one gives me 250 plus my
constant
so now having got a value for my
constant i can substitute that back
into let's just delete that my
my y equation right here's y and you can
see that this
is just going in tubes it is e this is
going into where the constant belongs so
that's why you can see it ends up as
that minus 250 along the end there
okay take a breath um if you've been
following so far and i do apologize i
don't know why i'm
i'm speaking fast reflexively for like
if we're in online class and i'm trying
to get you to the end
before the bell that we can't hear will
go
but i hope that you've seen and you know
paused and rewounded the spots where you
needed to
see where the logic was going at this
point here
i now can sort of wrap this up in a nice
neat bow
i have a displacement equation in terms
of
time now normally we would say if
if it looks like this right y is a
subject so now substitute in some value
of t
to get y and the equation is set up to
do that
except i'm asking the reverse question i
have a
known uh y 32.5
and i have an unknown t so i look at
this equation i'm like uh oh
i've got a linear part here i've got an
exponential part here
i don't know how to solve this
analytically is the way we'd say it by
looking at it doing some factorization
or something like that so therefore
you can see i'm going to need to use
some technology to help me
and i'm going to want to graph for this
and then find when is it equal to 32.5
when does it collide
so therefore um i have done this a
little bit earlier as you can see
here's my equation uh 50t plus 250 e to
the
minus a fifth t and so on and so on and
it gives you this uh it gives you this
curve here
and uh i don't know how to solve this
analytically but i can actually just
plot for myself y equals 32.5
and that's the line up there and in
order to find
when the first equation equals 32.5
desmos if you didn't know this already
can find points of intersection for you
so in fact
all i need to do is just click on one of
the lines and you can see in gray there
the point of insertion appears
you click on that and bam you get a
value so this is let me see if i can
make that a bit bigger for you i already
have okay
so that is where is it 2.786 so if i was
doing this to
a couple of decimal places i guess it
would be 2.79
seconds and if you think about that to
yourself
um you can see why this is a reasonable
answer you've got about 30 meters to
cover
and you know that acceleration downward
is at a rate of 10 meters per second
per second um but of course you're
slowed down a little bit by the air
resistance and so you can see you're
at least doing a sense check you're in
the right ballpark and that's your
solution
so i hope you found that helpful um if
this is a tricky question like i said
and you probably wouldn't be posting
something like this
in an exam unless they wanted you to do
something
like some kind of approximation right
for for this answer so
um you know you have access to a bunch
of approximation methods that could help
you if you got given a bit of a
leg up into the question in the old
course we had this method called
newton's
method which enabled you to find
solutions to awkward equations like this
or i should say
find approximations of solutions um and
you know as extension two students
there's no reason why you couldn't be
asked to use something like that if they
showed it to you you're not expected to
know it off
on the top of your head but you might be
able to use a formula that you've never
seen before if they actually spell out
to you how it's um how it works
so i hope you gave this a good go before
actually watching
the solution if you spotted any errors
in my answer please let me know
or if you tried it a different way and
got something else feel free to you know
send that to me in a message and i'll be
happy to have a look at your alternative
solution